un confinement strict et des résultats
plusieurs semaines plus tard voilà le
plan de lutte contre le coc vite 19
mises en place par le portugal qui
semble avoir fonctionné avec des
chiffres épidémique désormais sous
contrôle
le gouvernement portugais a annoncé son
plan de déconfinement progressif nous
avons un calendrier de réouverture qui
commence le 15 mars et dure jusqu'au 3
mai pour lundi prochain
je souhaite d'abord souligner les
activités liées aux enfants c'est à dire
la réouverture des crèches et des écoles
élémentaires ensuite concernant les
activités commerciales
la réouverture des commerces de biens
essentiels uniquement pour les retraits
en magasin ainsi que la réouverture des
librairies et aussi des salons de
coiffure et activités similaires
manet kutch et ses moulins si les
chiffres continuent à évoluer dans le
bon sens le plan de déconfinement
passera une nouvelle étape début avril
les collèges monuments et musées ainsi
que les terrasses des restaurants et
bars pourront rouvrir
puis les lycées et universités théâtres
et salles de restaurant suivront deux
semaines plus tard en attendant le
confinement reste en vigueur jusqu'au 4
avril
la population ne pourra sortir que pour
les achats de première nécessité sauf
dérogation le télétravail restera
obligatoire et la circulation entre
communes limiter le week end
un dernier effort demandé par le
gouvernement à sa population
ils seront capables si nous avons pu
pendant deux mois nous conformer aux
règles et obtenir des résultats aussi
remarquable après avoir été pendant
quelques jours dans une des pires
situations au monde afin d'être
maintenant capable de compter le plus
petit nombre de cas dans l'union
européenne
ce que nous devons faire maintenant
c'est maintenir cette trajectoire et ne
pas gâcher ce que nous avons déjà réussi
à réaliser pour pouvoir retrouver dans
la sécurité
toute la normalité possible pour nos
vivable tous ces vins de jeunesse juive
la prudence est donc de mise pour
retrouver une vie normale éviter le
retour de l'épidémie s'il a bien géré le
passage de la première vague épidémique
le pays a sombré face aux variants
anglais
fin janvier le portugal enchaîné les
records quotidien deux d'essai devenant
le pays le plus touché au monde
en termes de contamination par rapport
au nombre d'habitants incapable
d'endiguer l'épidémie de kobe 19 le
portugal avait même appelé à l'aide
l'union européenne un appel entendu par
la france l'autriche ou encore
l'allemagne depuis le portugal s'est
enfermé dans une bulle qu'il s'apprête à
rouvrir progressivement